it's gonna happen
um now you obviously
correct me if I'm wrong I know you have
songs with
quavo
offset did you ever do one with takeoff
no man unfortunately the last time
I spoke to take off it was at one of
these cookies events right and uh cuevo
had a strain drop so it was really
cuevo's event but takeoff was there too
right and I was you know in the back
chopping it up whatever we smoke one I'm
like take you the only me go I don't
have a record with yet you know what I'm
saying he's like I see what you're doing
bro come on you know I mean send me a
joint I'm like I got you and I [ __ ]
never did wow and it's really because a
lot of times I had a few of these
opportunities Nipsey too and I'll tell
you about that story but it was like
remember you know last time yeah you
think you have time and I was like I
want the right record the one thing
about me is like I got a lot of like
amazing features blessed you know what I
mean but like
the compliment I'm getting from most
people is like yo you're using these
features on the right song for sure
right way you know what I mean I
remember I pressed play on a lot of
people
um and DJ head was at the studio at my
studio and I was playing him all the
joints and he was like yo I didn't
expect all this but then he said this
specific thing he's like yo I'm the most
impressive thing is like how you use
your features like you got the best out
of everybody you know what I'm saying so
yeah because some people will get a
feature and you'll be like why'd you put
this guy on an album cut right exactly
you know what I mean and that was my
thing because I understand it's a big
deal to get a song with these guys for
someone in my position you know what I
mean so you know and sometimes it takes
a little while to get that right one
every time I'm in the studio I'm like
would this one work for takeoff nah not
really let me you know what I mean and
then that [ __ ] happened man this [ __ ]
was crazy